after taking a leadership role on root
causes
the actual root causes invest in the
root causes
the overall issue which is root causes
on the root causes
you can't just react to a problem
without
solving it at its roots
well there you go root causes a record
number of illegal immigrants are making
their way into the u.s
but don't worry as you saw our borders
are is finally getting to the bottom of
those root causes
today vice president harris unveiled her
five-point plan to combat the crisis
of course no mention of securing our
border because that would have required
six points and there just wasn't any
room
no no kamala believes a social justice
overhaul is the answer she
wants to throw money at the northern
triangle to win hearts and minds and
address issues like economic insecurity
and inequality and that of course is
insulting to those nations but whatever
meanwhile reports are joe biden will be
meeting with a group of senators to
discuss an
amnesty plan so they are very very busy
obviously
uh joining me now chris stegall uh radio
and podcast host of the chris stegall
show
and fox news contributor katie pavlich
katie let me start with you
uh not only is it does it and she
insulted the guatemalan president when
she was there talking about how she you
know needs to help their country and
things problems need to be solved there
is this even any of our
business isn't the border our business
isn't this country our business
why are we suddenly focused on changing
those countries from the inside out
well because that would be saying that
you're solving a problem without
actually
solving a problem that you created and
that you actually are
benefiting from politically in the long
term the interesting thing about that
that
is then solving the root causes in
guatemala for example is just this week
the state department announced that they
were cutting ties
and negotiations and cooperation with
the attorney general in guatemala
because
there were too many corruption issues
which of course we knew about
before she decided the vice president
decided she was going to go there and
try to change
years and years of corruption in that
country the bottom line is that the
root causes of the current crisis and it
is a crisis
it's actually a scandal considering
they're sending thousands of coveted
positive
individuals into american communities
while they tell the rest of america to
go back to lockdowns and mass and
and to change their behavior the root
causes are coming from the white house
the root causes are coming from the
democratic party
that gives illegal immigrants benefits
like free health care
that allows them to travel the country
on the taxpayer dollar with a bus ticket
and a plane ticket wherever they would
like to go
without having any kind of restriction
and of course now we're seeing that 70
percent of
or greater of these people are not
showing up for their ice hearing
surprise
essentially if you show up in america
now you get to stay
and that is beneficial for democrats
because they would like these people to
eventually vote
for the democrats well i have to say i
want both of you to take a look at this
because the american people despite what
the democrats think and the
establishment think aren't dumb babies
drooling right with no thoughts in their
heads
let's take a look at a new poll when it
comes to how the vice president
president are viewed
uh their unfavorable rating kamala
harris 46
joe biden 43 percent uh you know it is
uh it's that is of course creeping up
the it's
the favorable rating is going down uh
chris i think that this is a reflection
that americans are noticing this
that the border is not some far-off
thing that doesn't affect them
uh you know the towns at the border one
of them is having problems because they
have released
covet positive people were never told
about it
let alone the seeding people into the
interior of the country
i know you recently spoke with former
head of ice uh what's your take on this
he informed me that we're already to
something like a million in the
in the fiscal year folks that in this
pandemic
have illegally crossed this border you
know victor davis hanson our colleagues
said
we're probably on pace at this clip
maybe two million annually that's
small that's large metropolitan cities
crossing the border illegally not
one of them said the former ice director
vaccinated and not that i expect our ice
officials and our border officials to
vaccinate they're not doctors for
heaven's sakes but
democrats aren't insisting on those
folks being vaccinated which makes this
all a joke we continue to read these
ridiculous stories of the daily beast in
politico about branson missouri or lake
of the ozarks as these
hot spots we're not dumb i'm from
missouri
the show me state and show me what
you're doing about the border which is
zip millions of people unvaccinated as
you said seated all over the country and
we're the problem we're the ones that
need to be punished
please you know it's interesting katie
uh and
you've alluded to it uh uh very uh
perfectly uh
that this is perhaps not a mistake that
this is what they want
that that it is a crisis and strangely
enough
with all the talk about caring about
covet and people's health
even making the trek if you have covet
19
put you at great risk the children who
never make it
these are the people who are supposed to
be the champions of the downtrodden
and yet their policies are condemning
those very same people to death and
suffering
and to in you know an internal dynamic
where they have no real power
and will continue to be sick because of
the desperation of what they face
how do we explain this being an actual
policy
well tammy i mean the democrats and the
biden administration have completely
emboldened the criminal cartel elements
of this i mean i was in arizona in april
to visit the border there and to see
what was going on and what had changed
since joe biden came into office
and the smuggling unit said that now
human beings are worth more money to the
cartels in terms of trafficking
than drugs are and so they're making
upwards of 25 million dollars a day
to traffic these human beings into the
country and then the biden
administration is perfectly happy to
finish the job by taking these people
and putting them on buses
without properly testing them or
quarantining them and sending them to
american communities all over the
country now those people are making a
choice to pay the cartels right
but there's this bigger question of why
is the bite administration putting
border patrol agents at risk of getting
covet yeah
ice agents at risk local law enforcement
at risk of getting coba then of course
they
clearly don't care about american
citizens getting covered
from illegal immigrants we gotta be
vaccinated we do we gotta go
clearly great points all thank you both
now up next hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis
you will not get it anywhere else